when the gods granted king midas one
wish he wished that everything he
touched would turn to gold midas was
delighted trees rocks buildings all gold
but soon he found in horror that his
food turned into gold as well when he
hugged his daughter to soothe his pain
he realized his mistake too late the
richest man in existence was starving
heartbroken and alone humanity got a
similar wish granted when we learned how
to turn brown stinky goo into magic
plastic cheap sterile and convenient it
changed our lives
but this wonder of technology gotten out
of hand
plastic has saturated our environment it
has invaded the animals we eat and now
it's finding its way into our bodies
[Music]
what is plastic for most of our history
humans used stuff we found in nature to
build the things we need it but the
invention of plastic roughly 100 years
ago completely changed our world plastic
is made from polymers long repeating
chains of molecule groups in nature
polymers exist everywhere the walls of
cells silk hair insect carapace ease DNA
but it's also possible to create them by
breaking down crude oil into its
components and rearranging them we can
form new synthetic polymers synthetic
polymers have extraordinary traits they
are lightweight durable and can be
molded into almost any shape not
requiring time-consuming manual work
plastic can be easily mass-produced and
its raw materials are available in vast
amounts and incredibly cheaply and so
the golden era of plastics began
bakelite was used for mechanical parts
PVC for plumbing electric gears and
cases acrylic is a shatter resistant
alternative to glass and nylon for
stockings and war equipment today almost
everything is at least partly made from
plastic our clothes phones computers
furniture appliances houses and cars
plastic has long ceased to be a
revolutionary material instead it became
trash coffee cups plastic bags or stuff
to wrap a banana we don't think about
this fact a lot plastic just appears and
goes away
unfortunately it doesn't since synthetic
polymers are so durable plastic takes
between 500 and 1,000 years to break
down but somehow we collectively decided
to use this super tough material for
things meant to be thrown away 40
percent of plastics are used for
packaging in the u.s. packaging makes up
1/3 of all the waste of the discs
generated annually since its invention
we have produced about 8 point 3 billion
metric tons of plastic 335 million tons
in 2016 alone more than 6.3 billion
metric tons of plastic have become waste
since 1907 piled up in one place that
makes a cube with a side length of 1.9
kilometers so what did we do with all
this waste 9 percent was recycled 12
percent burnt but seventy-nine percent
of it is sticking around still a lot
ends up in the ocean around 8 million
tons a year
that's so much plastic that it will
outweigh all the fish in the ocean by
2050 because it's everywhere
marine animals keep getting trapped in
plastic and swallowing it in 2015
already 90% of seabirds had eaten
plastic many animals starved with
stomachs full of indigestible trash in
2018 a dead sperm whale washed up in
Spain he had eaten 32 kilos of plastic
bags nets and a drum while this is
tragic and makes for great magazine
covers there's an even more widespread
invisible form of plastic micro plastics
micro plastics are pieces smaller than 5
millimeters some of them are used in
cosmetics or toothpaste but most result
from floating waste that is constantly
exposed to UV radiation and crumbles
into smaller and smaller pieces 51
trillion such particles float in the
ocean where
even more easily swallowed by all kinds
of marine life this has raised concerns
among scientists especially about health
risks from the chemicals that are added
to plastic BPA for example makes plastic
bottles transparent but there's also
evidence that it interferes with our
hormonal system de HP makes plastics
more flexible but may cause cancer it
would be pretty bad if micro plastics
are toxic because they travel up the
food chain though a plankton eat micro
plastic small fish eat zooplankton soda
wasters crabs and predatory fish and
they all land on our plate micro
plastics have been found in honey in sea
salt in beer in tap water and in the
household dust around us 8 out of 10
babies and nearly all adults have
measurable amounts of phalates a common
plastic additive in their bodies and 93
percent of people have BPA in their
urine there is little science about this
so far and right now it's inconclusive
we need a lot more research before panic
is justified but it is safe to say that
a lot of stuff happened that we didn't
plan for and we have lost control over
plastic to a certain extent which is
kind of scary but just to make sure we
should simply ban plastics right
unfortunately it's a bit more
complicated than that plastic pollution
is not the only environmental challenge
we face some of the substitutes we'd use
for plastic have a higher environmental
impact in other ways for example
according to a recent study by the
Danish government making a single-use
plastic bag requires so little energy
and produces far lower carbon dioxide
emissions compared to a reusable cotton
bag that you need to use your cotton bag
7,000 100 times before it would have a
lower impact on the environment than the
plastic bag
we're left with a complex process of
trade-offs everything has an impact
somehow and it's hard to find the right
balance between them plastic also helps
solve problems that we don't have very
good answers for at the moment globally
one-third of all food that's produced is
never eaten and ends up rotting away on
landfills where it produces methane and
the best way of preventing food from
spoiling and avoiding unnecessary waste
is still plastic packaging it's also
important to note where the vast
majority of the world's plastic
pollution is coming from right now
90% of all plastic waste entering the
ocean through rivers comes from just ten
rivers in Asia and Africa the Yangtze
and China alone flushes 1.5 million tons
of plastic into the ocean each year
countries like China India Algeria or
Indonesia industrialized at an
impressive pace in the last few decades
transforming the lives of billions of
people this development was so fast that
the garbage disposal infrastructure
couldn't keep up with collecting and
recycling all the new waste this brought
if politicians in Europe in the u.s.
want to address this issue investing in
infrastructure in developing countries
is just as important as fighting plastic
pollution at home with campaigns and
redesigning products to minimize
unnecessary plastic production the
bottom line is as long as we don't
address plastic pollution from a global
perspective we will not solve it plastic
pollution is a complicated problem we
found a magic material and we had a
really good time with it but we need to
be careful or just like mitis will end
up in a world that we didn't wish for
your individual daily actions still have
a huge impact what you do matters refuse
disposable plastics convince your
friends and family to do the same
pressure companies and politicians to
take the necessary steps to keep our
oceans clean and our food safe together
we can beat plastic pollution this video
was a collaboration with UN Environment
and they're clean seas campaign if you
want to take action to turn the tide on
plastics go to clean seas org and make
your pledge